I pretty much started this entire family
no one would be anywhere or anything
without me the theme for this party each
other
Kylie you could sit next to me because
you are my favorite on Sunday season 17
finale of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
we watched the sisters epically
impersonate one another Hey yes they
fully committed with hair makeup and
wardrobe just like that effortless look
you know but it's really a lot of effort
Kourtney turned into Kim did my butt get
smaller
Chloe became their mom Kris Matt vodka
you have my Birkin right okay thank God
Kim turned into Kourtney I'm just like
pushing my way through life by myself
Kris became Chloe you know I invented
the word okay okay and both Kendall and
Penelope dressed as in absent Kylie she
will always be the dearest to my heart
for a billion reasons dressing up was
just one of the many activities that
Kris orchestrated she's been mediating
the ongoing dispute between Kim Khloe
and Kourtney over Courtney's future on
their reality series after a year of
speculation the episode ended without a
clear answer on what Kourtney will do
moving forward
life is short it's not I'm all about
filming this show yeah about enjoying
that's why we're doing this so then we
have time to enjoy I don't have time to
enjoy I'll do something else
et sat down with Kim Kourtney and Khloe
in October you mentioned that you might
be ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up
with the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there and
still but I'm not saying goodbye right
but I think you'll have to see more of
it on the new season season 18 do you
think the show can continue going if you
lose a sister yeah I mean we definitely
love portney and we will miss Courtney
and whatever she decides to do but
people come people go all the time this
family we are feel like at the revolving
door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back Ryan Seacrest
who's one of the executive producers on
the show shared his two cents when et
spoke to him in June the Kourtney
Kardashian said she would be happy if
the cameras went away she would if the
cameras go away as long as they can come
back Courtney you know they can go away
for a little bit but bring them back so
we can do another season or two Alyssa I
don't know how honestly I don't know how
they do it they've lived for over a
decade with cameras following I could
not do it and no matter what they were
paying them I couldn't do it so I give
them a lot of credit from those cameras
in their lives all the time and I love
you coordinator
[Music]